[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zur wahl des militär des jahres
20 21 schön dass sie dabei sind wir
zeichnen angehörige des österreichischen
bundesheeres aus die besonderes
geleistet haben und zwar in den
kategorien
rekrut des jahres zivilbedienstete des
jahres einheit des jahres und soldat des
jahres auch zum special awards werden
vergeben kommen wir gleich zur ersten
kategorie zur kategorie des rekruten des
jahres hier kommt ein überblick über die
drei nominierten
[Musik]
nominiert als rekrut des jahres sind
gefreiter alexander flatscher zusammen
mit rekrut maximilian schröder durch ihr
beherztes eingreifen können sie im
rahmen des assistenzeinsatzes an der
burgenländischen grenze drei verdächtige
schlepper festhalten und der polizei
übergeben
[Applaus]
rekrut wolfgang böcker wird bei einem
medizinischen notfall durch rasches und
kompetentes handeln zum lebensretter
[Musik]
und wer jetzt rekrut des jahres wird das
verrät uns nun general leuten an franz
reißner meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich freue mich sehr ihnen den
rekruten des jahres präsentieren zu
dürfen
unsere crews des jahres wurde im rahmen
eines orientierungslauf es zum
lebensretter eines kadersoldaten der
siebten jägerbrigade durch seine rasches
und kompetentes handeln
die paar mit der richtigen diagnose
verdacht auf herzinfarkt wurde so einem
teilnehmer das leben gerettet wo es gar
pirker stabilisierte den patienten
entschied selbstständigen transport zur
nächsten sanitätsdienst stelle und
alarmierte die rettung als fach
dienstlicher ersthelfer hat er somit für
den reibungslosen ablauf der
rettungskette gesorgt so dass der
betroffene branche ist möglich und
bestens versorgt ins landeskrankenhaus
villach gebracht werden konnte der
patient musste am herzen operiert werden
er befindet sich gott sei dank auf dem
weg der besserung
ich gratuliere herrn rekruten wolfgang
bürger zur wahl zum rekruten des jahres
er hat sich diese auszeichnung durch
seinen hohen ausbildungsstand und sein
couragiertes vorgehen in diesen
medizinischen notfall mehr als verdient
wolfgang türk es ist mir eine ganz
besondere freude und ehre ihnen den
preis zu überreichen das interoute des
jahres herzliche gratulation
rekrut des jahres 20 21 wolfgang becker
geboren am 5 dezember 2002 in tehran
gemeinde liebenfels in kärnten an der
landwirtschaftlichen fachschule althofen
absolvierte er die ausbildung zum
landwirt schaftlichen facharbeiter eine
ausbildung die er dringend braucht
und es wird käse abstellt wenn man natur
soll es verkauft
das ist 24
uhr in dem 24 7 job findet becker
schnell seine lieblingsbeschäftigung er
isst am liebsten personen kühl und im
stall ist
abgelaufen und kai schumann und die für
mich wo ist eine studie dabei kennt er
jede kuh zumindestens anhand ihrer
nummer manche bekommen sogar einen namen
das ist eine
zutrauliche
kontrolle war um zu kühlen wie happy
feet hat pirker auch eine besondere
beziehung was nicht heißen soll dass
alle anderen tiere auf dem hof in
irgendeiner form vernachlässigt werden
musik für kontrollieren
und abbildung einer woche gehen auch
wenn er sich anschaut was frisst und
familie trotzdem gibt und wolskis muss
hat die all stars muss entweder
dementsprechend verhandlungen die
käseerzeugung bahnhof ist nach wie vor
im bewährten händen hier wird auf
traditionelle
herstellungsmethoden wert gelegt auf die
oma seit 40 jahren und stellt
jetzt mit angestellten und
trotzdem strebt wolfgang palka eine
fortbildung im ausland an
wo man schon
konnten wir dazu braucht käse milch eier
und alle anderen erzeugnisse des hofes
kann man direkt vor ort auch kaufen
direkt und über hauptstraßen
aufgebaut
in seiner freizeit verfolgt wolfgang
pier gar eine seiner leidenschaften
kostüm
als klares votum aus kaufte beckloff
direkt aber seitdem wohl gern gelaufen
aber trotzdem aber jetzt in der zeit vor
dem spiel dass er dabei ist
da laufen wir sind
vorgeschrieben ist
im juni 20 21 rüstet der rekrut des
jahres schließen japan seine zeit beim
bundesheer hat er nur positive
erinnerungen
er hat wie er sagt das beste daraus
gemacht sie wurde in erinnerung es hat
alles gepasst hat oder ausbildung oder
sanitäter konnten hoffen mal komplett
normalen ausbildung
und ja und gepasst
falls nichts
herzliche gratulation dem rekruten des
jahres wolfgang böcker in der nächsten
folge zeichnen wir den zivilbediensteten
des jahres aus ich hoffe dass sie wieder
mit dabei sind und freue mich darauf
[Musik]